[Musique]
le premier album de charlotte cardin est
celui d'une chanteuse libérez moi je
sais ça et c'est vraiment un album est
un processus créatif qui meurent permis
de me libérer de mes mains c'est plein
de choses
[Musique]
découverte en 2013 à l'émission la voix
charlotte cardin s'est rapidement
illustré sur scène mais aussi sur
internet
en cumulant près de 117 millions des
côtes avec ses premières chansons
[Musique]
le temps était donc venu pour un album
complet fine x est le fruit de trois ans
de travail il a été enregistré à
montréal et mixé à los angelès une chose
fondamentale c'est que cet album est
gelée vraiment fait pour moi plutôt de
les faire en pensant peut-être aux
attentes ou le faire en essayant
d'anticiper ce que les gens voulaient de
noix et choqué que j'ai souvent fait
dans ma vie
épidémie
avec phoenix charlotte car des chantiers
blessure en prêchant sont résolument
féministe la place de la fin des
injustices qu'on peut vivre en tant que
femme mais je parle aussi d'amitié je
parle d'amour bien sûr qui est un thème
principal
sur la pièce s'exprimer l'auteur
compositeur interprète post la note et
parle de sexe vraiment une chanson way
qui parle du fait que des fois des
relations ne pas envie que ce soit plus
que physique on n'a pas envie que ce
soit quelque chose de très sérieux puis
je trouve que des chansons comme ça ont
souvent été écrite de la perspective de
l'homme
le nouvel album sera disponible dès
vendredi mais le lancement virtuel aura
lieu la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
depuis mai radio canada
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]